I miss you
I did not like the image of that oh my
God I feel like I threw up in my mouth
Kim's son Jamal and Usman meet in person
for the first time in Nigeria and I know
that all I'm about to see in the
comments is Jamal is so fine Jamal is so
fine yes he is handsome but let's not
allow that to distract us okay he is the
voice of reason that Kim needs in her
ear right now I feel like you didn't
like me
I'm her son you know like I've seen her
get screwed over by so many men
especially after Usman revealed that
instead of taking on a second wife he's
considering adopting his brother
Muhammad's child and having Kim help
raise the baby
his Muhammad's uh child and I love him
so much so I was like why not optimize
my son take care of him and rebuke
myself forever it sounds like it could
be endearing but instead it's a whole
mess that gets even Messier when Usman
reveals that his brother knows nothing
about his plan
so Muhammad doesn't even know that
you've been thinking about adopting this
child
I did not tell him what I want to do but
I invited him there in abujah I don't
know about you but I personally would
feel guilty taking a child away from his
mother and father just so my dreams
could come true look at this little boy
he doesn't look like he wants to leave
his daddy and his daddy definitely looks
like he doesn't want to give him up
let's get into it
hey 90 day fans fam it's melissia oh I
took a week off I got some rest now I'm
feeling rejuvenated I hope you're
feeling good and if you're not hopefully
our time together makes you feel better
before we get into Jamal and Usman
meeting face to face first I want to
give you an update on shaida and below
[Music]
it feels like I could be up here forever
being with my favorite human being in
the entire world and now until kids come
ah for now for now these two are still
in New York City and after taking a nice
romantic helicopter ride shadowless
below know that she's not going to allow
the romance to distract her from the
fact that time is ticking and she
deserves a clear answer from him about
when they're gonna try to have a baby
I'm not going to be in a relationship
with anyone whether they give me the
moon or the Stars
and not have a child
whoever said that they wasn't having a
child
I have been very consistent since the
time I met you up until now
with everything you are the only one
that I've ever met who's constantly
changing
after the doctor's visit everything
shouldn't be consistent that should have
been a shift
to you just a refresher I know I've said
this before but I'ma say it again just
so you know the doctor tells shadow that
her ovarian reserve is low so at the age
of 37 if she wants to conceive naturally
she and Below needs to start trying as
soon as possible I am so serious you
need to give me an answer and I have to
see if I'm comfortable with that answer
shadow goes on to tell Bilal she's
giving him up to nine months to give her
an answer meanwhile he thinks she's
being inconsiderate of his feelings and
not taking into account that this would
be his child too and not just hers
it's almost like it give me an ultimatum
there's a reason why I sometimes have my
guard up
lets me know that you're not 100 and
you're not in Blau y'all are married why
are you testing her she's clearly in in
my opinion this has nothing to do with
her being a hundred percent or being in
what this is about is a woman who has a
dream of being a mother to birth her own
child and her time is running out period
anyone who has ever wanted something
really bad and knew the chances were
slim can understand her anxiety this is
her life her Legacy time she's not gonna
get back and you know what I really
think is going on here is that but I was
scared but I was scared that history is
going to repeat itself he revealed in a
previous episode that having kids with
his first wife and she leaving him was
traumatic so to me him making this
statement about shaida not being a
hundred percent or being in there's a
reason why I sometimes have my guard up
lets me know that you're not 100 and
you're not in just proves that for one
he tends to flip things back on her if
he doesn't trust her I don't see why he
married her in the first place and two
that he's allowing his fear of a worst
case scenario based off of what happened
in his past to drive his decisions and
his current relationship which
is understandable it happens but
he should consider taking some time to
work through that I'm 100 but it's kind
of big going your way all the time baby
none of this is going my way I do
everything for you
let me ask you something what have you
done for me
for me
oh goodness below
I'm not gonna either answer that
question wrong exactly you don't want to
answer it Shy
I will she left her family behind in
Trinidad she left her business behind
and she signed your prenup
come on below if someone was to say that
to me I would say look I'm giving you
the gift of my presence that's doing a
lot right there I know it sounds Petty
but frankly it's facts also side note I
think people should be careful when they
say things like what have you done for
me in a relationship now some people
really are with people who don't do
anything for them but I think it's
important to remember that people show
and give love in different ways just
because below my do a lot for Shada in a
material sense doesn't mean that what
she does for him which might not be as
visible isn't just as worthy if I don't
get an answer from you when it comes to
having a child like how soon
that will definitely break our
relationship
and I
mean every word that I say
is beyond hurtful to hear should I say
that this could break us if she believes
that having a baby is the only thing
that validates us being together then
it worries me that she really really
wants to break up like if you don't do
it my way then it's the highway I
personally didn't get the gist that
shadow thinks having a baby would
validate them as a couple the way I see
it she just wants to have a child of her
own
[Music]
way to ruin a moment
from men is that you don't have to say
everything you think it's like he wants
her to feel bad fast forward Shada meets
up with her friend uterus before she
heads back to Europe and uterus So shyta
the plan she came up with after chatting
with Bilal so I was thinking
what if he accidentally takes your birth
control pills
if I
you chose this is the next thing I never
open you up on I'm also no birth control
pills he is using protection
I'm yes so there's no like not taking
birth control pills to try to get
pregnant Jesus Christ this is worse than
I thought
so he plays me when he told me basically
that
if you get pregnant you're welcome the
child and he's using meal contraception
yeah hon he does not want to have a
child at all costs uterus goes on to ask
shida if she had to choose will she
choose her marriage or having a baby and
shy gets real like right now how I feel
I was just having a baby
I'm glad she stuck up for herself but
she needs to toughen up and don't waver
in her opinion because basically that is
whole
he's going to basically get his way with
her so if she's not pregnant in nine
months
she just needs to go leave him now the
question is how is she going to handle
the nine months is she going to continue
to bring it up is she going to give us
some space to breathe
it's going to be interesting to see how
it all plays out I'm not sure what's in
store for these two but present day they
seem to be doing fine at least on social
media they are making a number of reels
with a hashtag couple goals I know
social media isn't always the best
reflection of reality but
things seem to be working out
either way time will tell alright let's
get into the biggest must-see moment
from this week Kim San Jamal and Usman
meeting for the first time in person the
main reason for my trip is to find out
more about this adoption thing because
it's a lot to think about for me and for
Usman it's been four months since Kim
last Saw Usman the last time they were
together the immigration attorney shut
down their plan for Usman to marry a
second wife so he can have a child she
made it clear that polygamy is illegal
in the U.S now as Kim mentioned she's
headed back to Nigeria to learn more
about usman's plan to adopt his
brother's son and she's taking her son
Jamal with her my son loves you you know
that I hope you're fine too
especially this last episode I was like
guess Jamal be the voice of reason yeah
time to shut up
it's going to be really important for
Jamal to be by my side when I meet
usman's nephew the child I may adopt
because this child will be in Jamal's
life too and I want to have Jamal's
acceptance because I really don't know
if I could raise a child in an
environment where Jamal is against it I
think my mom is really going to try to
force me to like Usman or something
um I just hope he's himself he doesn't
try to do too much because I'll see you
right through that
I think that when you see him in person
and you see how him and I are together
it's going to make you feel better about
the relationship you know I hope so yeah
speaking of seeing how Kim and Usman are
together once she and Jamal arrive in
Nigeria things get off to an interesting
start for Jamal after he sees his mom
locking lips with Usman
bro what's up what's up man nice to meet
you nice to meet you you're looking good
hi baby
wait let's see that face one more time
Jamal
with the stretch his body language
screams awkward
love you love you baby so let's go right
yes
I miss you
I did not like the image of that oh my
God I feel like I threw up in my mouth
but it's my first time out of the U.S uh
I'm glad to be in the motherland
honestly I know that's right I know my
mom wants my support
but I don't really trust Usman and I
don't really want Usman to prove himself
to me I just want him to be himself
because I'll notice if he's trying too
hard you know I can read a room really
well
you all right yeah Usman looks extremely
happy right now once I get to the hotel
and get settled they sit down to have
dinner together it just kind of hit me
I'm like I don't know the last time I've
sat with you and like a boyfriend or
fiance or anything like we all just like
ate together you know like a family it's
crazy yeah kind of weird Usman is kind
of giving off step dad Vibes right now
he goes on to tell Jamal that he hopes
Nigeria will become his second home just
like it's Kim's
just the way it is
and Jamal found a way to kindly tell us
man hold on hold on bro
I just got here I mean we'll see how
this trip goes you know what I'm saying
I feel like you didn't like me
I'm her son you know like I've seen her
get screwed over by so many men
the only thing that bothers me a lot is
like you know like I've been with her
for like a year plus
if I'm not a good person
there is no how she can hide it for you
for a year well what Kim has told Jamal
over the past year has him concerned I
think it's safe to say that Usman isn't
a terrible person okay but the situation
has not been ideal learn to get you a
gift
what yeah Usman blindfolds Jamal with
what appears to be a pair of his pants
and goes to get the gift I'll be honest
I thought to myself was getting Jamal a
gift Kim's idea or usman's you know Kim
is good with the gifts y'all remember
the laptop the PlayStation and the
Soulja Boy chain that she gave Usman
before they were even in a relationship
yeah but you know I thought about it I
said I'm gonna give Usman the benefit of
the doubt maybe it wasn't Kim's idea to
get the gift maybe he thought about it
on his own and bought it himself
let me know what you think I would love
it for me and him to be like close to be
friends to get along because he has a
lot of power in my relationship with
Kimberly
and I am not having him to come and try
to control me or control his mom while
I'm with her well that takes the heart
out of the gesture
and then open your gift
conceal it
wait
no way bro
who's been no way dude
there's no way a whole PS5 bro wow those
PlayStations turn grown men into the
happiest of kids what
hey I gotta sit down
I don't even know what to say no it's
cool bro I asked nothing from you don't
respect
and I'm not asking you to respect me as
your father I'm asking to respect me as
a man
Jamal I want you to know that
he's she's safe I will never break her
heart never say never let me stop I hope
he sticks to his word the night ended
with Jamal feeling pretty good about
where things stand between him and Usman
Usman bought me the console and
everything and it's kind of cool how
like my mom got him one then he gets me
one it's kind of like a full circle if
that's how you want to look at it Jamal
okay obviously I'm glad I didn't go
completely bad because it shows that me
and Usman do have you know potential to
you know actually develop some kind of
positive relationship
okay good night all right thank y'all I
feel like it's Christmas yeah love you
oh love you too oh sweet well the next
day Kim Usman and Jamal meet up with
usman's friends and they have a nice
little bonding experience
I know you are a professional
[Music]
it is really cool to just sit there and
watch Jamal hang out with Usman and his
friends
they loved they love Jamal
and so does the internet once everyone
sits down and takes a break from the
game Usman starts to discuss his plans
to adopt his brother Muhammad's son is
that a normal thing you know like our
brothers who adopt his brother's child
here in Nigeria you can adopt a child
like from your own blood from your own
blood yeah exactly your bum your blood
is your blood and what Usman says next
personally I was not prepared for you
know I didn't even talk to my family
about this you know right yeah I don't
know
I didn't
wait so Muhammad doesn't even know that
you've been thinking about adopting a
child
I did not tell him what I want to do but
I invite him there in abujaram that's
sneaky this is a child a human life that
baby is not a pawn it seems as if Usman
thinks that this is his world and
everyone else is just living in it so
they don't even know why they're coming
why do they think they're coming in turn
up Jamal
why do they think they're coming in
and I told them that they're going to
meet kimbala and kimberlyson and they're
happy with that
you know this whole time I thought
Muhammad already knew that USA wanted to
adopt his child but they're about to go
and find out if Muhammad's even going to
let them take the child away my mom
trusts him for his word but like I'll
Trust you when I start seeing his
actions match his words I don't know how
truthful he is about my mom and this is
another thing that takes me a step back
towards trusting him Usman dropping this
bomb completely rubbed Kim the wrong way
as well I thought you told him but I
told them that they should come watch
but I thought you already said oh my God
I thought you already told them that us
know why do you always do this to me
because
you never told me that you didn't tell
Muhammad that we have I didn't tell him
nothing why because I feel like we need
to how can I just go and make decision
without you but you you kind of are
though you're oh my God no no listen
babe why are you worried this is not
this is not something for you to be
stressed out good you know like if your
father is here though he know or he
didn't know it doesn't matter you're
gonna handle it so it doesn't matter
where's the respect for his brother and
it's not like Usman initially wanted the
boy to come with him to the states so he
can have a better life Usman wants him
to come so he can get his green card and
be with Kim the baby having a
quote-unquote better life would just be
a byproduct I feel totally blindsided
right now Usman told me a half story I
thought I was coming here to potentially
try to form this little family and to
come to find out Muhammad doesn't even
know anything about it this whole
adoption thing seems doomed and I cannot
believe I came to Nigeria for this
darling come down
that's not drama that's just messed up
in my opinion
I agree well next week it looks like
Usman is going to bring his plan up to
his brother and I can't wait to hear his
response
we were thinking you can give us mahadi
to adopt him as our child huh
I feel like usman's just going too far
I'm not going to feel usman's brother's
baby this is crazy crazy don't worry
like we are going to take care of him
100
this is wild and the little boy is so
cute all right 90 day fans fam make sure
you stick with ET because we are
covering it all I will see you next time
[Music]